last year u.s politicians absolutely
destroyed the s p 500 these politicians
were better traders than hedge funds on
wall street there's a brand new report
out from an unusual whale on twitter and
what he did was he broke down the
financial return of a bunch of the
politicians in our government there are
hundreds of millions of dollars that
were exchanged on the stock market by
our elected officials last year in just
equities they bought and sold nearly 290
million dollars throughout the year in
2021 congress on average beat the market
something incredibly hard to do this
report showed which sectors that they
preferred there was big legislative
events this is a key part such as the
infrastructure bill getting passed they
were often preceded by politicians
trading in the sectors affected and
there were tons of unusual trades when
politicians made millions of dollars
congress has 45 days to disclose trades
to the public but sometimes they're late
and you can see a list of the late
disclosures and some politicians also
held sec securities in the sectors that
they vocally expressed support for such
as senators holding cryptocurrencies
while drafting crypto regulations
there's 35 politicians that were able to
across the aisle both republicans and
democrats beat the s p now 35
politicians out of just over 500 may not
seem that crazy but there's way more
than 500 hedge funds and only three
major hedge funds last year were able to
actually beat the s p 500 three major
hedge funds in the united states
actually beat the s p 500 but 35 u.s
politicians were able to pull off that
feat
these hedge fund managers are paid
millions and millions of dollars a year
in fees to do everything they can to sit
and dedicate their time energy and
financial resources to study the market
to research where opportunity lies to go
long and short and to beat that
benchmark of the s p 500 but yet
politicians whose day job has nothing to
do with finance has nothing to do with
investing has nothing to do with
researching securities they were able to
do it even better than the hedge funds
it's absolutely nuts are the politicians
insider trading what constitutes insider
trading how concerned should the
everyday citizen be about the fact their
politicians are day trading or using
exotic trading instruments like options
and actually trading in the exact same
assets that they're legislating on we
live in a society where the politicians
appear to be better investors than the
hedge funds and that is very suspicious
if we then continue on this report we've
got a bunch of other graphics here which
you can see is that the estimated
returns on options trading
absolutely nuts
60 35 30 12
how is it that our politicians are such
experts at options trading
maybe there be one or two that came from
a financial background who previously
were options traders that would be okay
but when you start seeing 35 investors
being so effective and beating the
market
and they just happen to be taking a
bunch of options out right before big
events
just begs a lot of questions
and so then if we go ahead and we look
at the total value of the assets bought
and sold by congress in 2021
they're just yolo long in stocks
democrats republicans independents this
is not
a condemnation of any one political
party this is everybody they're all
doing it
and they're all
just investing and trading
and not spending time legislating our
country has been in shambles we
literally had a global pandemic ravaged
the country
we had an economic recession
followed by high levels of inflation the
highest we've seen in 40 years
and our politicians found enough time to
trade so
much money the congressional trading
total amount of assets traded year over
year
it's absolutely nuts
what we saw over the last two years is
that almost a billion dollars of stocks
were traded by congress in the last 24
months
options trading coming in at over 150
million dollars worth but ultimately
what's fascinating to me
is that we had three federal reserve
high-ranking members
have to step down from their job for day
trading the same assets the fed was
buying
our politicians are buying many of the
same assets
they're also advocating for various
legislation
and they're trading in these assets
there's a number of proposals that have
been put forward that maybe our
politicians shouldn't be allowed to hold
individual stocks they shouldn't be
allowed to trade like this
and whether you think they're being
unethical or not whether you think this
is corruption or not and whether you
think that they should do this or not
the key in my opinion in this situation
is not what they're actually doing or
how they're doing it or what their
intention is it is actually the
perspective of impropriety we should be
able to trust our politicians we should
be able to believe that they are focused
100 of their time on representing us on
helping us improve our lives on helping
us actually achieve financial security
freedom and happiness but if instead
they're off trading enormous amounts of
money and they're financially benefiting
to the tune
at which they are maybe actually what we
should be allowed to ask is
what is enough when will we actually
pass legislation that will not allow
these politicians to hold individual
assets and trade them we quite literally
have individual employees at financial
institutions at our banks at our hedge
funds etc that have more controls on
them than our politicians our
politicians are allowed to participate
in the financial markets more than an
entry-level banker it's crazy on top of
that when you start to look at our media
politicians are allowed to participate
in the financial
markets more so than almost all
journalists journalists don't even hold
individual assets for the most part and
so why do we allow our politicians to do
that there's a lot of questions i don't
have the answers but i do know that when
35 politicians are able to outperform
the s p and only three major hedge funds
are
a lot of people are scratching their
heads saying to themselves man maybe the
reason why people want to be a
politician is not because they're
altruistic it's not because they want to
represent the people maybe it's just
good for your personal balance sheet